[Musique]
selon la relationniste a devant nous une
démarche aux organisateurs la pologne
pas d'inquiétude
je parle français je m'appelle rares
marouf j'ai 18 ans je suis avocat je
suis arrivé en france en 2013
j'avais 15 ans je suis le président de
rennes cricket club
j'écris avec mes amis hommage janvier
vous connaissez le cricket
non vous savez que c'est le douzième
sport pratiqué dans le monde
le cricket est rentré dans ma vie en
afghanistan
mais tout d'abord laissez moi de vous
raconter mon histoire je commençais à jd
le coran en avant à la madrasa madrague
m'adresse vous dire être au service des
autres
j'ai été 30 minutes pour aller à pied
j'ai dormi là bas la semaine on était
des tares jusqu'à n'avoir à 10 heures le
soir musique jeudi m'intéressait
énormément la journée consacrée à la
lecture du coran aux explications de
texte courant
je n'ai pas appris à écrire à compter
mais c'est une chance d'aller à l'école
coranique
j'apprenais et mes parents étaient fiers
de moi je suis même ce que vous dire je
peux diriger la prière dans une mosquée
de la madrasa il y avait beaucoup de
talibans armés passé tout le monde
l'avait très fort
un jour les talibans et m'emmener avec
les autres enfants j'avais 11 ans les
talibans nous entraîner avec dix arbres
et des kalachnikovs
je donne aux talibans je voulais pas
faire la guerre il l'a frappée j'étais
menacé de mort car j'ai refusé d'aller
combattre avec pitard juste devenu un
ami avec un jeune talibans qu'elle va me
chercher pour la prière de tous les
jours un matin elles sont venues ouvert
la porte de ma chambre plus tôt il m'a
expliqué le schéma il y avait personne
j côté son conseil et je suis parti les
talibans étaient très énervés ils sont
venus me chercher chez mes parents
elle met le feu il fut la maison ma mère
et ma soeur et sa mort dans le faux mon
père a été blessé
il m'a dit bateau il faut qu'ils
quittent l'afghanistan
il m'a confié à mon oncle pourquoi je
fais le pays mon oncle il va rencontrer
un bassin et nous sommes partis j'ai
traversé au spi le pakistan l'iran la
turquie la grèce la bulgarie de roumanie
hongrie italie en france
j'ai marché
j'ai pris des camions du bisse des
bateaux j'avais sauf j'avais fait
j'avais pas et j'avais 14 ans pour
chaque étape il faut attendre parfois
plusieurs mois que l'ia c'est déjà pour
le trajet j'ai mis un an pour arriver en
france pour quitter l'afghanistan j'ai
porté un pantalon et une chemise pour la
première fois que je n'ai jamais porté
un pantalon
avant on ira j'ai vu des femmes nos
vallées dans la rue pour la première
fois en turquie
j'ai vu des gens faire bisous dans l'art
est encore une première fois tous les
gens qui fait voyager avec moi il
voulait aller angleterre là bas on peut
gagner beaucoup d'argent mais on ne
tient pas le pas fait on peut faire des
études mais on peut pas avoir un diplôme
quand je suis arrivé en france à paris
j'avais que 2 0 en poche je suis allé
dans une première cyber café pour faire
skype avec mon oncle mais c'était plus
que de 0,4 en a réfléchi je suis allé
dans une deuxième cybercafés et les
messieurs mais elle est surtout les
halls skype gratuitement
j'ai parlé à mon oncle je le dis je suis
d'autant plus que je connais pas
j'ai pas l'argent j'ai pas mangé depuis
une semaine j'ai pas pris de douche
comment je voulais faire il m'a dit il
faut que tu restes là bas
tu as traversé au spi pour arriver là
bas on m'a dit je veux rien faire pour
toi j'étais énervé j'ai rappelé à mon
oncle pour lui demander de l'aide
il m'a donné mon numéro de téléphone de
mon cousin à rennes j'ai contacté mon
cousin et je suis venu à rennes une
ville gros et jolie quand je suis arrivé
coallier à s'occuper de moi qu il ya ce
couple de demandeurs d'asile
c'est une association il m'a trouvé une
chambre d'hôtel plus une famille
d'accueil
j'étais si quoi une famille d'accueil ma
famille sur l'afghanistan
je voulais rester seul
comme mon cousin travail et gagner de
l'argent mais je fais plein de choses
avec ma famille d'accueil
au début c'était très compliqué pour moi
je comprenais pas un mot de français
nous nous posons tous beaucoup de ges
mais tu attends attends à regarder
toujours le sourire
si une famille avec des enfants
je suis resté chez eux deux ans il m'a
beaucoup aidé et je suis très attaché à
eau quand j'étais dans cette famille je
suis entré à l'école mais c'est pas les
mêmes choses car l'école coranique il y
a des plans de matières des maths des
français d histoire il ya les plans des
matières d'autres que je n'ai jamais vu
je suis rentrée au collège en quatrième
la première jours la première heure
je viens contrôle de maths de maths j'ai
rendu une feuille blanche
je dois expliquer en anglais je ne parle
pas français je ne savais pas écrire la
première jours c'était très compliqué
pour moi les filles les garçons ensemble
à l'école faire bisous les français les
cultures j'ai appris plein de choses en
alcool et j'ai recommencé à jouer le
cricket
quand je vous disais tout à l'heure le
cricket est le douzième sport pratiqué
dans le monde il ya 120 millions de
pratiquants dont la fin de la planète
pour le coupe du monde de cricket de
2015 un milliard de personnes à regarder
le match de l'andrh pakistan à la
télévision c'était le plus qu le coupe
du monde de football et les jeux
olympiques
j'ai déjà joué en afghanistan mais là
bas c'est très compliqué surtout c'est
très dangereux à cause de la guerre un
jour un ami
il m'emmenait au terrain de cricket à
rennes c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert
qu'il y avait d'autres afghans à rennes
j'étais trop content je recours aussi à
jouer le cricket
tous les samedis et acheter des
matériels j'ai trouvé un terrain je
voulais notre indépendance alors que je
mentais notre club et j'écris une
association c'est une grande chose pour
moi
maintenant on a un terrain official si
un terrain de baseball avec des
visiteurs
on a aussi un seul pour entraînements
plus l'hiver si grâce à la mairie de
rennes
nous avons une équipe moins de 18 ans la
ville a aussi la demande est monté lui
une équipe de filles je suis le
président de rennes cricket club
[Applaudissements]
grâce à au cricket je suis un peu connu
ils m'ont contacté l'éditeur souvent qui
connaissent d'autres afghans
je suis allé avant à lorient angers
saint malo pour rencontrer des gens à
tous je le dis il faut aller à l'école
qu'on apprendre à lire à écrire à parler
français il faisant aller vers les
autres
s'intégrer dans la vie à prendre c'est
une chance pour moi c'est très important
de faire des choses pour les autres je
peux pas donner de l'argent mais je peux
les aider
voilà j'ai raconté mon histoire
aujourd'hui je rendre aussi à rennes
qu'il m'a beaucoup donné
j'espère dès l'année prochaine
d'où trois joueurs de rennes cricket
club qui va sélectionner une équipe de
france j'ai bon espoir et j'y crois je
suis au havre je suis le président de
rennes cricket club
et je suis rennais
[Applaudissements]